when you were a kid was that something
that you were fascinated with just
causes and oh yeah wasn't so malicious
oh yeah what was right that way as a kid
were you were you intrigued by that like
causes and think we were there things
that you just really yeah as a job as a
kid I wasn't so interested in the causes
and kind of the ripple effect in that
regard but more the ripple effect that
was take place in myself when I would
watch movies that you know that would
just inspire me and move me you know I
my parents were around somewhat to raise
me but you know the most most of my
upbringing my education happened in the
movie theater you know the people I
wanted to be like the lessons that I
learned that I that I sort of had been
consistent in my life over the years
have all been kind of from movies that
I've watched so yeah and that's partly
why it's partly what inspires me to be
in this business and to tell these
stories and continue doing this and
fight to keep doing this is because I
know that it's still most effective
means to tell a story and to move people
and to communicate a message
you